and so here's that code in practice the
first thing we do is loop through each
of the tile set images checking the
first GID against the tile index once we
find the correct one
we'll break out knowing that I is the
proper index once we find this we can
set the pkt image value to equal the
image of the atlas and then we go
through and do a little bit of math to
determine what the tile offset is now
recall that the tile index is actually
added to the first GID for this array so
167 as a tile index is actually Atlas
with GID one tile 166 we remedy this by
actually subtracting the tile index from
the first GID giving us local index from
there we can do a little simple math
given the local index in this number of
tiles horizontally for this Atlas to
give us our x and y indexes once we have
the indexes we can multiply them by the
tile size to give us our pixel X and
pixel Y finally return packet and we're
good to go